What on earth am I wearing right now?
What is this sorcery?
How did I go from a stay at home mom covered in poop all day to this?
Okay, this is the dress for the ladies who want to keep it classy
but are still a little bit sassy,
okay? Because. Okay,
well, the booty.
The booty is still there. I hate y'all.
I hate sweater dresses with a passion.
Everyone knows this about me.
Because if you're a little thick or curvy or just had a baby like me,
we don't want the added inches.
They add, like,
two extra inches to your already curvy body.
This is like a suede, and it looks knit,
but it's not. It's like a suede.
Really light, really comfortable.
I get claustrophobic. This is not claustrophobic whatsoever,
y'all. $15 if you wanna feel like a woman tonight.
Thank me later. The link is right there.